jeune vivier est le premier refuge créé
par la société protectrice des animaux
la spa en 1904
dès l'après guerre son but abolir
l'euthanasie systématique et immédiate
des animaux errants sur la voie publique
c'était alors une obligation légale
pratiqués par la fourrière
la plupart des chiens qui franchissait
cette enceinte était promis à la chambre
à gaz dans un délai de 48 heures
la spa de jeunes vivent y multiplie donc
les actions pour éviter l'euthanasie
recueil et identification des animaux
errants et en 1960 elle remporte une
victoire capitale
le 4 juin 1960 décret de la préfecture
de police de paris
supprimait la fourrière au bénéfice du
refuge de gennevilliers le refus obtient
donc la gestion de la fourrière pour
toute la région parisienne pour avoir
une chance de supprimer l'euthanasie il
tente de faire adopter le plus d'animaux
possible mais le nombre d'abandons
explose
le refuge est plat plus de 300 chiens
plus de 200 chats y attendent que la vie
leur rendre ce qu'ils ont perdu
contrainte et forcée face à l'afflux
danew la spa de gennevilliers n'a
d'autre choix que de recourir à
l'euthanasie
autrefois combattu un drame pour le
personnel
si nous piquons un animal c'est parce
que les en avant tout c'est parce que
nous en apporte de trop à qui
croyez-vous que ce soit la faute à nous
qui sommes les employés ici et qui nous
devons faire ce travail
le public qui en fait l'élevage et qu'il
abandonne à la mauvaise période
dans les années 70 80 le centre
multiplient les appels aux dons et les
campagnes d'adoption mais l'euthanasie
reste une variable d'ajustement
le quotidien pour ce vétérinaire qui
piquent 40 chiens par jour
vétérinaire
oui dans les années 90 même constat le
centre suffoque 640 pensionnaires pour
382 places en 1996 la directrice de
gennevilliers mène une action choc elle
ferme le centre aux abandons pour six
mois et demande l'aide des collectivités
locales pour le financement de nouvelles
antennes de la spa et ça marche
nous avons trouvé un site à orgeval pour
le 95
nous attendons de nouveaux sites dans la
région parisienne depuis 2014
la spa a mis en place un réseau de
familles d'accueil partout en france ce
qui a permis de supprimer l'euthanasie
sauf pour raisons médicales en 2018
seul 418 animaux ont été euthanasiés
dans les 62 refuge et maison sp.a du
pays
[Musique]